en este momento la situación en nanter
sobre todo en las cercanías de la
prefectura donde terminó la
manifestación es caótica hay
enfrentamientos al menos hace unos
minutos cuando salimos de allí hay
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
policía ellos lanzan piedras fuegos
artificiales contra los agentes del
orden los agentes del orden responden
también con granadas lacrimógenas y es
una escena realmente caótica la que se
vive en ese momento en los alrededores
de la prefectura de nantear es
pudiéramos decir la antesala de una
tercera noche muy violenta tanto aquí en
plantear como en el resto de las
ciudades colindantes con la capital
francesa y probablemente en otras
ciudades del país porque como lo
mencionabas hay un gran dispositivo
policial adicional desplegado en todo el
país las personas que con las cuales
pudimos conversar nos decían que no es
suficiente con los anuncios que se han
hecho no es suficiente con los
desplazamientos de la primera ministra
de los de los ministros que han estado
en en las zonas las negociaciones de los
propios diputados en los barrios
populares de aquí delantera
específicamente la ciudad de la de Pablo
Picasso y de Puente Viejo que no es
suficiente esos anuncios del procurador
de nanter que explicaba cómo va a ser el
proceso judicial contra El oficial que
cometió el asesinato que permanece o que
va a estar preso esperando su juicio
nada de eso para ellos es suficiente
esta simplemente es la gota que colmó el
vaso las personas se sienten acosadas
por la policía se sienten que los las
fuerzas del orden no los tratan con
respeto no los tratan con humanidad y
precisamente por eso se han volcado a
las calles y manifiestan de esa forma la
ira que tienen acumulada durante muchos
años desde el la entrada del ministro
geraldo de armanam nos decían varias
personas con las que pudimos conversar
hay temor los padres temen que no pueden
controlar a sus hijos que sus hijos no
los escuchan y que toda esa ira se va a
continuar manifestando es apenas el
comienzo nos decían muchos manifestantes